tu connais cette sauce tu s bien ce
qu'il y a
dedans de l'arfumé des champignonsir la
crème fraîche le caré d'au s'il vous
plaît le Napoléon de la gastronomie le
prince le roi du persil et aussi du
paprika et on ajoute de la jolé grosille
c'est très bon ce qu'on a fait mais tout
ça me donne l'impression d' brouillant
esquiss nous sommes à l'automne de notre
vie parle pour vous je me sens en plein
été je vous le demande encore
marions-nous nous passons plus de temps
ensemble que bien des époux à étudier
des recettes à les faire ne sommes-nous
pas bien ainsi je relève le Paris
d'émerveiller le prince avec un poau feu
de ma composition avec votre aide c'est
un peu risqué
et
audacieux je suis si heureuse et
reconnaissante il faut de la culture de
la mémoire pour que le goû se
forme tu do te souvenir de ceû
Monsieur de au de la reine
pouroous a àers ce que vous
mangez pas de je para bien pas
bien bonhe c'est de continuer dés ce
[Musique]
déj
J